situated amidst an arid desert the
stunning blue pools are hard to miss
these freshwater pools are poses are
located in Quattro Siena gus' a
butterfly-shaped basin nestled in the
mountains of northern Mexico over 300
poses spam the roughly 800 square
kilometer region the area is teeming
with biodiversity a unique box turtle
and other one-of-a-kind vertebrates drew
researchers to the area in the 1960s but
what's kept them coming back is a little
harder to spot compared to similar low
phosphorus salty environments Quattro
Cienega has an extremely high diversity
of microorganisms such as archaea and
bacteria some of these unique microbes
have been found on stromatolites layered
mounds that form from microbes binding
sediment together with their sticky
secretions stromatolites dominated
coastlines over three and a half billion
years ago and were one of the first
visible signs of life on early Earth but
about a billion years ago they started
to decline living stromatolites are
extremely rare to come by which is what
attracted researchers like valetti Isola
Sal leave it so lhasa even has been
studying the area for the past couple of
decades and held many papers about the
microbes of the area some are direct
descendants of microbes found in the
ancient ocean and deep hydrothermal
vents but throughout the duration of
Sol's us I'll divide his time in the
area she and her team have faced an
imminent threat to their research the
expansion of agriculture in the 1970s
several canals were carved to drain
water from the poses and carry it to
towns and crops and neighbouring valleys
up to 80 kilometres away in the 2000s
alfalfa fields were planted adjacent to
the poses drawing more water from the
aquifer underneath with illegal wells
the basin was declared a protected area
in 1994 but only the unique species in
the area were included not the water
itself over 90 percent of the marshes
have disappeared as well as Elle Judean
same a three poza system
it dried up in 2016 in a race against
the clock shows us Aldi vet and her team
sampled as much as possible from the
pools before 2016 collaborating with
over a hundred researchers they
published more than 50 papers with data
collected from Elle Judean say what they
found help them learn more about the
history of Quattro Sienna cos they
sequenced the genome of bacillus
bacteria living there and discovered
links to two ancient ancestors from 680
million years ago and 160 million years
ago those dates could be linked to the
breakup of supercontinent Pangaea and
rodinia when the area was situated in a
marine environment and the ancestral
bacteria could have established
themselves the poses themselves have for
more recently on the scale of thousands
of years not millions active faults
helped push the water up from beneath
the basin and as it rises it likely
passes through ancient sediments
collecting minerals and microbes
researchers believe that most of the
poses in the area are fed from the same
source of groundwater Sol's asal David
needed evidence to support this theory
in 2006 agricultural institutions
proposed installing deep wells to water
alfalfa in an adjacent Valley and locals
approached her team fearing the wells
would dry up their poses despite claims
that alum Dino Valley had its own
separate water reserve so la salle de
odd compared samples from Three Valleys
eluned IDO Calaveras Valley and Quatro
Sienna cos she found a highly similar
bacterial composition among men
suggesting that the poses from the Three
Valleys are linked by a connected source
managing the water not just inside but
outside the basin might be crucial to
protecting these unique pools as of July
2020 there are plans to close one of the
major canals in cuatro Sienna cos as
well as regulate illegal groundwater
wells which have popped up throughout
the basin the future of the area is
bright so is us al diva and her team
have been training local students had a
sample and analyzed the poses leaving
them with the tools to continue to
protect this
place for decades to come
[Music]